how can you be born in the desert the
Virgin's house ago and breath mine is
purified and this morning me crying
Kenan wings joined forces against some
of you bros I had two versus two in guns
of Icarus it was a lot of fun so I'm
gonna play some more with you bros so if
you want to play with me go ahead and
check the link in the description or
watch the end of the video and joy oh
there's a level 10 and 12 on the other
team is gonna go well for us
oh really oh I'm a level three gunner we
got this wait your name is you're a
steer
not a captain a steer steer nice scarf
bro I can hear me don't tell me where to
hammer hey get your head out of here oh
gosh hammer fall a steer better that
look look at that bad girl hmm work it
yeah I'm on a boat like a music video
good hey why don't you talk for kid - I
behind guys I'm buff you're gonna cry
yeah like 360 degrees behind us God are
we gonna do a Harlem shake now or what I
don't know what the other one is I say
Adi yeah you want to be able to do a
Harlem shake now that's a shoot fighting
the HMS windhammer well it up Jamie see
it buffs when you're hammering it hit it
whoa yeah yeah yeah cry they're not dead
so I know but there's no [ __ ] wake
and hit them more with that alright here
we go here we go Amanda done oh [ __ ]
they got her ass hey I hit the [ __ ] out
of that guy with the guns oh god I can't
steer yeah I don't know why they all
just dance Thanks fix the fans I just
fell off the boat I'm working on the
fence don't worry about it just keep an
eye out
I think Kenny's pressing buttons okay
cloud of black smoke behind the ship so
you must be pressing like the 1 2 and 3
buttons and stuff yeah we like an egg to
piece yeah if you put out the black
stuff it destroys our engines right
same gun broken make stop bugging
goddamnit I'm working on it let's get
broken
Mami's be not doing her job I'm back I'm
not fixing try to fix stuff but it's
just go to [ __ ] exit God is marking rock
on [ __ ] wrecking them [ __ ]
we can't Chad Levick stand by the
engines Oh fiery I can still I knew
you'd do it
whoa a flame um believe it man he's so
flame that's it
oh hey it isn't damaged there holy [ __ ]
with the big guns
ahh make gun broke right when I was
gonna do it dang it fix the big gun
please done Felix I'm dealing don't work
it on everything my work oh come on
Oscar Oscar Oscar fine okay cry cry cry
cry cry Eddie knows good guy to fix
stuff I gotta damn it shoes went for the
hole oh it's getting absolutely wrecked
that poor hell why that happened I
ignore the hole that was my fault
because you to fix the main gun that's
what I did it was just me when we die
seriously when it died we they killed
the other [ __ ] oh nice alright we gotta
get win River we got a random with
bullet
RAM um oh that's a great idea we gotta
kills because gang right and to the left
way I'm marking them for you
that is that I'm there Mulder okay okay
Lee wait what about that bow but now we
gotta go win rammer
it's like Casper the Friendly bite don't
worry about it huh that's a good one to
the left so I could hit it with the
Catholic
we're buffing you cry hey welcome nice
hey those our buffs don't try to take
credit cry should waive my rights the
air board starboard there it is I see
him lift
that's our friend that's our friend he's
already marked alright
like right front front cannon firing oh
my gosh hey I did it
sweet okay right go to this one go to
this one no go to this one right links
is doing it now never now that God
thinks you're missing ever Oh cry you
destroyed the hell finish him off
alright uh turn left left left left left
left up and down left and down it takes
to don't make it take time make it go
just make it work we don't need you oh
why are we on the ground cryos ordered
firing yeah alright
and I'm buffing you're gonna cry hey
everybody my god somebody should I have
gun I reload that thing I got it i okay
car I've got it buffing - got it
you're gonna kill it ah oh damn babe the
Love Boat [ __ ] ain't [ __ ]
what bad pilots and [ __ ] yeah I thought
it was our best game yeah good not bad
not bad it out mmm-hmm won five scrubs
you tell em GG no [ __ ] that we we
wrecked them that's no okay fine GG
dad I don't know how to dry the tesha
solji yeah I'm 4G alright press I hope
you enjoyed watching some guns of Icarus
if you want to play some guns of Icarus
with me and some bros join us the 23rd
of December at 8:00 a.m. GMT time it
should be pretty crazy you could be like
20 people in one game so all of that
info is in the description rose leave a
like me enjoyed watching I really
appreciate it it's a scar
rather day and a see you and the next
one brofist
you